I did it
it feels good yeah probably I know I am
it'll be exciting when it went doing
what uh what I'm doing isn't isn't
trailblazing anymore but I'm very happy
to have gotten this all right so I think
and you had the whole room in hysterics
we're hearing it here and what kind of
like going on a night out were you like
if you would take me out well I like to
I like one on one so I think we would
probably be at my apartment and we would
get drunk at home - yeah yeah I'm like a
homebody but I do like to tie one on
yeah yeah and so what would be your
advice for like young women in comedy
get vaccinated for HPV and what else uh
no I think - just get on stage as much
as possible and don't worry about
everybody liking you just do what you
think is funny how who is that anyone
out there tonight that you're gonna be
desperate for a selfie with at some
point um I'm so desperate for a selfie
with Goldie Hawn that I'm not even gonna
ask like cuz I just I I would just want
it for me I'd probably look at it like
every night like goodnight I just love
her so much do it